Hey youtubers it’s Charlie and they did
some very big comic book moments on Walking
Dead this week so we need to talk about those
and the big WTF cliffhanger at the end.
Quick Reminder new giveaway starts now.
All you have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and leave a comment.
Lots of stuff to get through, so let’s get
right in it.
Careful for spoilers from episode 2 if you
haven’t seen it yet.
Starting with Top 5 moments.
Number 5 - Everyone Recaps the back half of
season 4 for each other
There were a lot of interactions we’d been
waiting for like Rick confronting Tara.
Which totally didn’t go down the way I expected.
He totally gave her a pass.
I mean, she’s a cast regular.
So she’s not going anywhere, but up till
she confessed her sins to Maggie in the church,
Tara stil felt like she was on everyone’s
shit list.
I’m really glad they’re able to act like
a family.
Who is apparently led by Baby Judith.
I loved the joke about Judith calling Rick
on the decision to go to DC.
I mean he made the decision but it’s all
about staying together.
Daryl couldn’t get Carol to fess up about
what she’d been through a la Lizze and Mika
but she did crack a smile.
And yes, I totally think she was about to
bail on them when Daryl found her.
Not bail per se, but just leave them.
As if she didn’t feel like she fit in with
the group anymore.
I’ve heard that the Carol Daryl story will
diverge, like that moment they took off in
the car was the beginning of a new story arc
for them.
I don’t know if they’ll find Beth, but
they might be how the show takes us back to
Atlanta.
The hospital where Beth is at is a big location,
I think that’s near Atlanta somewhere.
And supposedly we’ll get a Beth scene in
episode 3.
So we’ll find out what’s up.
Number 4 - Meet Father Gabriel
I’ve talked about him in a few of my bonus
videos before but as you could see, he holed
himself up in his church for months after
the apocalpyse started.
Based on the scratches on the outside “You’ll
Burn For This.”
It sounds like the show is staying faithful
to the comics.
I feel like it was pretty obvious what he
did based on Detective Carl’s work and Gabriel’s
reaction to the walkers, but I’ll put this
spoiler tag up while I talk about him in the
comics….okay..
So in the comics, Gabriel just refused to
let people inside the church.
He locked himself inside for months and survived
off the canned food drive they had done.
During the apocalypse most people would probably
go to churches and hospitals for shelter and
supplies.
so naturally he turned all those people away.
And he knew all of them.
He was their minister.
So he’s living with the guilt of that.”
okay, comics talk over.
Like Carl said, something crazy went down,
but he’s not the villain.
The church though, from the looks of the final
scene and the episode 3 teaser, will be a
battleground between the survivors and the
Termites.
Or The Hunters.
I guess technically we can call them that
now.
It’s possible they could wrap up the Church
storyline in the next episode and move on
to DC.
The Hunters storyline in the comics isn’t
super long.
But Gareth is a series regular, so there is
some confusion as to what they’ll do with
that character.
Number 3 - The Food Bank
This was the big action set piece like the
store at the beginning of season 4.
Remember that’s where we lost Beth’s most
recent boyfriend.
So of course it fits that something terrible
would happen to someone in a very similar
scene.
Actually I think it was bob that got trapped
that time too.
If I were superstitious I could say Bob has
been living on borrowed time since that rooftop
collapse.
Plus there was the time that the Walker only
bit “his bandage”.
Every season they always try to top themselves
with a big epic walker scene like this.
I still feel like the season 4 scene was crazier
in terms of tension.
But that might be because spending all this
time making walking dead videos has desensitized
me.
And I just can’t tell what’s scary anymore.
Gabriel is a total weakling but I did feel
sympathy for him.
That area is a really small town, so of course
he would know everyone at the food bank.
He’d seen all of them just a few months
ago.
And when he made like Jesus on the cross here,
that walker coming for him looked like one
of his aldermen or whatever you call the people
that work really closely with preachers.
He had been extra close to her.
So it would be like a best friend coming for
you.
Number 2 - The Washington DC Pitch
Abraham sells everyone, they’re going.
Right after they deal with Gareth and his
Hunters.
Eugene for all his mullet fast talking did
make a lot of sense.
DC is a major city with all the supplies and
shelter they need to last indefinitely.
So even if the cure took 20 years to fix things,
they could wait it out there.
Please comic book readers, use spoiler tags
when talking about Eugene and the cure.
The toast scene had this really nice calming
effect on me.
Most of the time you’re in oh shit mode
reaching for Katana’s that aren’t there.
I’m interested to see how the church bus
in the trailer here, ends up being used for
a Dukes of Hazzard moment.
Walking Dead Dukes of Hazzard.
That was the bus that Gabriel said they could
take.
So this scene could be from next week or it
could have something to do with the battle
with Gareth.
And my Number 1 WTF Moment - Bob Stokey and
The Hunters
For anyone that had questions, Bob went out
into the woods to die.
He had been bitten and just not told anyone.
during the food bank swimming pool fight.
Interesting that he still had sex with Sasha.
She’s going to be pissed about a lot of
things next week.
Gareth and the Hunters captured him without
knowing he’d been bitten.
And yes, they cut part of his leg off and
ate it while he was passed out.
This is a scene right out of the comic.
They left it on a cliffhanger, so I won’t
go too deep into what happens next.
But if you want to read more about it.
Just read the Tainted meat part of Volume
11 of the comic before next week.
It’s going to get crazy.
And I know they had that whole scene about
Michonne not missing her Katana, but she’s
holding it right here in the trailer.
So I’m guessing one of Gareth’s men has
it on him and that’s how she gets it back.
Let me know though, what was your favorite
moment and let me know if you think Daryl
and Carol will find out where beth is?
If you’ve read the comic you probably know
exactly what’s going to happen with the
people at the church, so I don’t want to
post too many spoilers about how that goes
down.
Overall I gave the episode a B plus, I loved
the way they cut the early montage scenes
with them traveling down the round.
Bouncing back and forth between people talking.
If you want to rewatch an amazing intro scene.
Bob Stookey’s is probably the best.
It has this amazing soundtrack.
It was during the back half of Season 4 but
I can’t remember which episode exactly it
was in.
All those episodes are on Netflix right now,
so it’s super easy to re-watch them all.
Even though they did a lot of comic book things
that telegraphed what the plot was going to
be, I still felt like they were able to use
the father gabriel church mystery to create
some tension.
The episode was mostly an intro to his character.
The Hunters part was really just the last
couple of minutes.
This is still the part of the season where
they set up the major story arcs, like the
search for Beth.
So don’t be surprised if episode 3 sets
up another big arc.
Carl had a great performance, he’s like
the moral conscience of the group right now.
Normally that would make me worried.
But since he’s not a big powerful figure
I think he’s mostly safe.
Scott Gimple and Kirkman said that they killed
TV Dale off early on because they felt like
offered a certain amount of comfort and safety
to the survivors and as writers, they wanted
to take that feeling of safety away.
Then the same thing happened to Herschel at
the prison.
So you really need to get worried when a figure
of authority tells everyone that there’s
nothing to worry about and they can all rest
easy.
Rick is safe because he’s telling everyone
that they’re about to die.
There is no safety.
In case you didn’t see it I posted a bonus
video explaining who the Hunters in the comics
are and how they’re different from Gareth’s
hunters on the show.
Click here to learn all about that.
And click here for my Q&A video.
That will post tomorrow.
Thanks for watching, now let’s all high
five and eat some tainted meat.